The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so,
we're going to pick up
on our study of
periodic potentials
and our search for
the explanation
of the physics of solids.
And I want to quickly
remind you of the logic
we went through last time.
This is one of the more subtle
bits of logic in the semester,
so I'm gonna do it
again, a little faster.
I'm mostly gonna do it in
a slightly different form.
I want to think for a moment
about just a free particle,
but I want to use
all the language
and formalism we used for the
periodic potential last time--
translation operators, the
block wave functions-- I want
to use all of that for
just a free particle.
So, first let's just
remind ourselves
how the free
particle story goes.
So, for a free
particle, by which
I mean the energy
operator is p squared
upon 2m, and no
potential, plus 0.
We have a very important
consequence of being free--
that the energy can be written
as just p squared-- which
is that the energy commutes
with the momentum operator.
And what this
tells us is that we
can find a basis of
eigenfunctions which
are common eigenfunctions
of E and p, right?
We can expand
every wave function
at any arbitrary-- fantastic.
Thank you, sir.
Oh!
Brilliant!
GUEST: Plan A, Plan B.
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
That's an awful huge straw.
Pay no attention to the
device beneath the table.
So, 'cause you know, it's
quantum mechanics, right?
Bowl of water--
So, the energy and
momentum commute.
And as a consequence, we can
find a basis of eigenfunctions
exists which are common
eigenfunction of E, E on phi E,
and I'll label k, by
the eigenvalue of k,
is equal to E phi Ek.
And p on phi Ek is
equal to h bar k phi Ek.
You'll notice, of course,
that I don't label it
by the eigenvalue,
but I label it
by something that's determined
by the label, the eigenvalue's
determined by the
labels, h bar k.
Now, here's the thing,
can we allow E and k
to be any values we
want independently?
Can I make E, 3, and k, 47?
No.
There's a consistency
relation, which
involves satisfying the
energy eigenvalue equation.
We actually have to find
solutions of these equations.
And once we find the
solutions are those equations,
we'll find relations
between k and E.
And in particular,
for a free particle,
we find that the relation that
we need is E is equal to--
and I will write E sub k--
is equal to h bar squared
k squared upon 2m.
This is also known as
omega is equal to h
bar k squared upon 2m.
Just to remind you,
the [INAUDIBLE] E
is h bar omega, omega sub k.
That's not the thing
I wanted to look at.
This is.
And when we work
this way, we find
that the energy eigenvalues,
E, as a function of k,
take a determined form.
And that determined form is
quite simple, it's a parabola.
Everyone cool with that?
So, if you know k, you
know E. But if you know E,
it turns out it's
doubly degenerate.
So, if you know E,
you're one of two k's.
You could be either
the ikx-- oh, sorry,
and I needed to say-- that
the function, so, from solving
the equation, gave us that
the energy eigenfunctions,
phi Ek are equal to some
normalization 1 over 2
pi as conventional,
e to the ikx.
OK.
So, if I tell you
the energy, you
don't know which momentum
state I'm talking about.
But if I tell you the
momentum, you know the energy.
So, there's a little degeneracy.
That degeneracy is coming
from the parity symmetry,
the system, right?
And note that what
we've done here,
did we have to write the
wave functions in terms
of these, the ikxes.
Is there another
basis we could've
used for the energy eigenstates?
Yeah.
Because these are
degenerate, we could've
taken any linear combinations
of E to the ikx and E
to the minus ikx,
and we could have
got, for example,
sine and cosine.
That would have
had the advantage
that the energy eigenfunctions
would have been pure real,
which is one we
proved was possible.
You can always choose pure
real energy eigenfunctions.
However, it would have had the
disadvantage that these states
would not-- sine
and cosine-- are not
eigenstates of momentum, right?
It's convenient to work with
common eigenstates of momentum
and energy, so we give up on
having a real wave function
and that's the cost of finding
shared eigenfunctions of energy
and momentum.
Everyone cool?
Any questions?
OK.
So, this is the usual story
for the free particle.
But we learn a couple of
things about it immediately.
Just by eyeballing
the wave function
we see some things to note.
Note, all states-- all
eigenfunctions-- phi sub
E, which are of the
form E to the ikxx--
and I'm gonna add the
time dependence in now--
minus omega sum
kt, are extended.
They have equal probability
density everywhere,
and the probability
distribution does not
fall off to 0 as we go far away.
And so, what this
tells us we have to do
is we have to build-- if we
want to study real localized
states that are normalizable--
we have to build
wave packets of the form psi
is equal to integral dk sum
overall momentum modes f of k E
to the ikx minus omega t sub k.
Where this f we will generally
take-- although we don't have
to take, to be a real function--
but, is peaked at some k0.
So, this is what we did when we
studied the evolution of a wave
packet of this form.
But in particular,
such wave packets
have a couple of
nice properties.
The first property
we've studied.
And if you're not
totally comfortable
with the idea of group
velocity, you really
need to go over it again.
It's be an excellent thing
to show up in recitation,
for example, stationary phase.
So, the group velocity
of such a wave packet--
as long as it's of this form and
peaked around a single momentum
value, k0-- the group velocity
is d omega dk evaluated at k0,
at the peak value
of the distribution.
And note, I wanna
just quickly note
that this is equal
for the free particle.
Omega is h bar k
squared upon 2m,
take a derivative with
respect to k, the 2 cancels.
We get h bar k upon m.
Which notably, is equal
to the expectation
value of the momentum
over the mass.
Everyone cool with that?
So, this gives us a
nice way to, by the way,
if you didn't know the mass, but
you could measure the system,
for example, you can compute
on average the momentum,
and you could compute
the group velocity
by watching wave
packets move, this
is a nifty way to
compute the mass.
The mass can be given by,
well, put the mass up here,
and divide by the
group velocity.
Measure the momentum and
divide by the group velocity.
OK, so, I can take
this, and notice,
that this just exactly
gives me the mass.
So, this is a way
to, given a system
with a momentum and
a group velocity,
I can compute an effective mass.
Which for the free
particle, is just the mass.
Cool?
Just a side observation.
But this is all a
consequence of the fact
that we have wave
packets of this form.
Their plane waves, or
at least things that
have a phase, times what could
be a real-- though it could
but an overall phase on the
whole thing-- a real function,
which is peaked at a
particular value of k0.
Usual wave packet story.
Any questions?
Good.
So, this should all
be pretty familiar.
Now, here's the
thing, when we talk
about a periodic
potential, what I
want to do next
is, I want to talk
about a periodic potential.
So, now, we have a system
that has maybe steps,
and it's periodic,
with period l, OK?
And then, ditto.
It's gonna be periodic.
And I want to run through
the same analysis.
I want to find the
energy eigenfunctions.
I want to organize
them in a nice way.
And in particular, I want
to know the following,
if this is equal to
v of x, and v of x,
and I call the
energy operator E sub
g is equal to p squared upon
2m plus a coefficient, g,
times-- let me call
it g sub 0, just
to make it unambiguous--
times v of x.
Notice that when g0 is 0, this
is just the free particle.
I added a periodic
potential times 0.
That is stupid, but doable.
But as I slowly turn on
g0, what's going to happen?
The energy eigenfunctions
are going to slowly change.
And the energy eigenvalues
And the actual system we care
about has some actual value of,
you know, like 7,
or e, or whatever.
But this is a way to
connect the free particle
to the particle in a
periodic potential.
You know, and if you just turn
on a little weak potential,
you don't expect the
system to radically change.
So, one way to organize the
question of periodic potentials
is, what happens
as you slowly turn
on this periodic potential?
But here's the first
thing I want to notice,
the first thing I
want to notice is
that it's no longer true
that the energy commutes
with the momentum.
So, it would be silly to
try to organize our wave
functions in terms of energy
eigenfunctions, which are also
momentum eigenfunctions.
Because that will only
be a sensible thing
to do when this
interaction term--
when this potential--
is 0, right?
So, instead, I want
to organize them
in terms of energy eigenvalues
and any other operator that
commutes with the
energy eigenfunction.
In particular, this
is not invariant
under arbitrarily
translations, which
it would have to be to be
invariant to conserve momentum.
But it is invariant
under translations by L.
And as a consequence, we
have that the energy operator
commutes with translations by
L. Where translations by L.
Takes a function and
shifts it over by L.
And so, because translations
by L as we showed in a problem
set long ago commutes with p
squared, because this is just
an exponential of Lp, with
coefficients, with an i
and an h bar.
And because the potential is
invariant under shifting by l,
and so it commutes
with TL, this is 0.
So, what this tells us is we
can find common eigenfunctions.
In fact, a common
eigenbasis of E and TL.
And here's the thing
that's nice about this,
I could've made this argument
whether the potential was 0
or not.
For the free particle,
it's also true
that the system commutes
with translations by l.
It's free, there
is no potential.
It sort of silly,
because I could've
just used the momentum.
But let's see what
happens if we use
the translate by l operator.
Everyone cool with that?
So, we want to find
common eigenfunctions.
So, as you guys showed
on a problem set,
the eigenfunctions of TL--
so, in order to do this,
what are the
eigenfunctions of TL?--
you showed that the
eigenfunctions of TL must take
the form-- sorry-- phi sub q
of x is equal to E to the iqx
times u of x, for some
q where q is-- where u--
is a real periodic-- I
don't really need the real,
but it's going to
simplify my life,
so I'll take it to be
real-- periodic function.
Well, let's just
drop real altogether,
because we don't need that.
We'll use a periodic function,
and phi of q is this phase.
It times the periodic function.
So in particular,
phi is not periodic.
And as a consequence, TL
on phi q is equal to E
to the iqL phi q,
because this guy shifts,
and this is invariant periodic.
So, this is the
form-- general form--
of the eigenfunctions
of translate by l.
And periodic means that u of
x plus l is equal to u of x,
just be to explicit.
OK.
So, what this tells us is that
the energy eigenfunctions can
be put in a form-- can be
organized-- as phi sub Eq,
such that E acting on phi sub
Eq is equal to E phi sub Eq.
Just like this line, phi sub Eq.
And TL phi Eq is equal
to E to the iqL phi Eq.
And it's just
saying then we have
common eigenfunctions,
yeah, with energy E
and TL eigenvalue, q.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, because
under translation by l,
this x goes to x plus l.
Oh, I've slightly
changed notation
from earlier in the course.
You're right.
I've slightly switched.
So, ah!
Good.
So, yes.
So, thank you.
So, let's fix notation.
TL takes f of x
to f of x minus l,
is what we've used
previously, right?
But I'm going to just switch
notation, and call this x
plus l.
So, for all the
notes in here, this
is x plus L. Yeah, it doesn't
really make a difference,
you just have to be consistent.
And you're right, I
switched between lecture--
what was it?--
eight, and this one.
Sorry about that.
Yeah, good catch.
Thank you for pointing that out.
So, in which case, this
shifts by x to x plus l.
And we get E to the iqL.
Good catch.
Good.
So, again, we have
this property that we
can find common eigenfunctions.
However, can E and q be
specified independently?
We know on general
grounds that it's
possible to find
eigenfunctions which
are common eigenfunctions,
because these guys commute--
E and TL commute-- so we can
find common eigenfunctions.
And here they are.
And, meanwhile, we know that
the form of these eigenfunctions
is of this form.
Because any
eigenfunction of TL is of
this form, a phase times
a periodic functions.
Does that, by itself,
tell us a relationship
between the eigenvalues E and q?
No, right?
Just like E and k
were independent,
until we solved the actual
eigenvalue equations, right?
And it required things
like regularity,
and no similarities.
So, what we have to
do at this point,
is solve the differential
equations for continuity,
periodicity, and solving the
energy eigenvalue equations.
And when we solve
the equations, we'll
get a relationship
between E and q.
And in particular,
if we do that,
here-- do I want
to do it this way?
Yes.
So, in particular for--
write this in the following
way-- for g equals 0-- g0 equls
0, which is a free particle--
we find E is equal
to h bar squared
q squared E sub q is equal to h
bar squared q squared upon 2m.
And yeah, and the wave
functions are of the form phi
sub qE are equal to some
normalization, 1 over 2 pi,
times E to the iqx.
And the coefficient
function, u, is
just constant, which is nice.
So, times constant.
And so, this is reassuring
because it's exactly
the same form of
the wave functions,
with exactly the same
form of the energy.
But where here, the
label-- the value-- q
is representing the
possible value of-- it's
controlling the
eigenvalue of TL.
So, there was a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, for the
translation operator--
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: --that
E iqx equal to x
will work for any complex q in
any u with period [INAUDIBLE]?
Or any periodic u
with [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
although, if q is complex,
then this is badly
non-normalizable.
Because if q has
an imaginary part,
then that function
is gonna diverge
in one direction or the other.
So, q had better be real.
But, that's correct.
This works for--
this expression--
A function of this form, a
periodic function-- periodic,
with period L-- times
an E to the iqx,
for any real value q,
and any periodic u,
will be an eigenfunction
of TL, translation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
It's not just non-hermitian.
It's, in fact, unitary.
I mean, what exactly
is your question?
Sorry, I'm misunderstanding.
AUDIENCE: So, I mean, just
the translation operator
has a really, really large
number of eigenfunctions?
PROFESSOR: Indeed, it does.
And that number is
the same as the number
of momentum eigenfunctions.
Because they can be
both used as a basis.
They're both operators whose
eigenfunctions form a basis.
That's exactly right.
So, I think the
difficult thing is
to think that--
we have a tendency
to think that there
aren't very many momentum
functions, for example.
But there's enough
momentum eigenfunctions
to be complete basis.
So, if this seems like a
vastly larger set, then yeah.
Indeed.
OK.
So, when we do our analysis for
the free particle of this form,
we get exactly the same story.
And I want to point out a
couple of consequences for this.
Working with this TL
operation-- or working with TL
eigenfunctions--- we have
exactly the same properties.
Our eigenfunctions
are, again, extended.
We have to use wave packets.
And those wave packets
move with a group velocity,
which is given by d omega dk.
On the other hand, here, when
we write super positions,
our general wave function--
our general wave pack, which
I'm gonna write
here-- psi, is gonna
be of the form integral
dq of E to the iqx
u of x times some f of x--
or sorry, f of q-- u sub q.
So, as long as this is a
periodic function, then
the-- oh, and I should
say minus omega sub qt,
to get the time dependence
in there-- as long as this
is a nice periodic function,
especially for this case
was, when it's real, and this
is a sharply peaked function,
which is sharply
peaked around some q0,
then we will find that the group
velocity is, again, the omega,
now dq, evaluated at
the peak value, q0.
And that's just a
general consequence
of this form of our wave packet.
As I encourage the
recitation searchers
to review by stationary
phase in recitation.
And secondly, again, we
can find this nice notion
of a mass, which
is the expectation
value of the momentum divided
by the group velocity.
And, again, this, for
our simple free particle,
this is just a nice way
of measuring the mass,
if you happen to want to do
so for your free particle.
No one told you the mass.
Everyone cool with that?
OK.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that still the
momentum when we have g0
is not equal to 0?
PROFESSOR: Excellent question!
So, now, let's study the
case with g0 not equal to 0.
OK?
So, so far we looked at for g0
no equal to-- or g not equal
to 0-- that was just this line.
But everything else,
was for general case
of studying common
eigenfunctions of E and TL.
So, now, let's
study the case for
an actual periodic potential.
So, in particular, repeat
for g0 not equal to 0.
And this is the analysis
we did last time.
We did exactly this analysis.
And we looked for the
common eigenfunctions
of E and translate by L, right?
And we found that the
common eigenfunctions
took the form Eq is
equal to E to the iq of x
times some u of x.
And now, we need to find what's
the relationship between E
and q?
Are any E and any q allowed?
And do those give
you eigenfunctions?
From the free
particle, we expect
that that's certainly
not the case.
On the other hand,
we have a guess
as to what it should look like.
The energy eigenfunction
for-- let me, actually,
write this here-- the energy
eigenfunctions and energy
eigenvalues, more importantly,
of the free particle organized
in terms of q, we
just immediately
see the energy is just h bar
squared q squared upon 2m.
So, the potential-- or sorry,
the energy as a function of q--
is, again, a parabola.
OK, so, here's q, and
here's the energy.
And this is for a
free particle, right?
Free particle.
E equals h bar squared
q squared upon 2m.
Now, I want to ask what
happens as we slowly
turn on the potential?
As we take g0 not equal 0.
So, we did this last time.
We turned on the potential.
We turned on the
a potential, which
is, in fact, delta functions.
So, now , in order to solve
the differential equations,
we have to actually know
what the potential is.
There's no getting around it.
And so, we took a bunch
of delta functions
with dimensionless strength
g0, and spaced by L.
And what we found was
an equation relating
E and L, which
took the following
form-- and for simplicity, I'm
gonna write E is equal to, this
has nothing to do with
momentum, although it looks
like momentum, I'm just
going to write E formally
as h bar squared Scripty
k squared upon 2m-- so, k,
here, should just be
understood as root 2m
over h bar squared, which I
hate writing out over, and over
again.
So, let me, actually, write
that the other way around.
Scripty k is equal to the square
root of 2mE upon h bar squared.
So, when you see k think E.
When you see lions, think lions.
OK.
So, we found that
the condition--
in order that we solve the
differential equations--
the condition, in order that E
and q label energy eigenstates
which actually are
energy eigenfunctions--
common energy
eigenfunctions-- of the energy
and the translation by operator,
we found that there was
a relation, which
was cosine of qL--
AUDIENCE: [SNEEZE}
PROFESSOR: --is equal to--
Bless you-- cosine of kL plus g0
upon 2kL sine kL, right?
So, first off, let's
make sure that this
agrees with what we found
when g0 was equal to 0.
When g0 was equal
to 0 we found that E
was equal to h bar squared
q squared for any q.
And, well, when g0 is equal
to 0, this term goes away.
And we get cosine of qL
is equal to cosine of kL.
And an example of a solution
for that is qL is equal to kL.
Or q is equal to k.
In which case, E is equal to h
bar squared k squared upon 2m,
by plugging in that expression.
Cool?
So, this reproduces the
free particle result
when we need it to.
But in general,
it's not the same.
So, what does it look like?
So, let's take a look at that.
So, here, first off,
what I'm plotting here
is the plot that we
draw on the board
last time, only here I'm
plotting it here horizontally
is the energy, E, and
vertically is cosine of qL.
Now, for q a real
number, cosine of qL
goes between 1 and negative 1.
And so, any value
in here corresponds
to a valid value of
cosine-- or of q-- sorry.
So, any value, any point,
between 1 and minus 1
is an allowable value of q.
So, for example, this
point, right here,
corresponds to this
value is q, OK?
Just horizontal lines.
Meanwhile, this curve
is the right hand side
of that expression.
It's cosine of kL plus--
or sorry-- in this case,
it's cosine of root
2mE upon h bar squared
L. This right-hand
side plugged in here,
and I'm plotting it as
a function of energy.
Just to be explicit, so this is
energy-- or energy-- and the q.
And here's that curve.
So, for g equals 0-- which is
what I've set it to here-- g
is equal to 0--
that didn't work,
there we go-- when
g is equal to 0,
we see that it goes
between 0, and this is just
cosine of root E. And
there's cosine of root E.
It gets spread out because
it's square root of E,
rather than E. Everyone
cool with that?
And so, here's my question,
what pairs of E and q
correspond to allowed
energy eigenfunctions?
How do you look at
this diagram and decide
which values of E and q are
good energy eigenfunctions?
AUDIENCE: Well, the fact
that the boundary conditions
of the q is such that cosine of
qL is between negative 1 and 1?
PROFESSOR: Good
AUDIENCE: Or all
values are allowed?
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
So, let me be explicit.
So, how would I find?
That's exactly right.
Let me rephrase that and
be a little more explicit.
So, what we need is we need
a solution of cosine qL
is equal to the right
hand side, in this case,
cosine of root
energy, L. So, that
means we need to find a
horizontal line corresponding
to a particular value of
q-- or a particular value
of cosine qL-- and a
point on the curve, cosine
of root EL, which is this guy.
So, at any point where
we are inside these two
extreme values, and this
E, will give us a value.
So, for example,
for this point-- ah,
I wish I could draw-- for
this point, that corresponds
to a particular
value of q, right?
Where the cosine of q is
equal to that vertical value.
And it corresponds to a
particular value of E.
So, each point, here,
corresponds to a value of E--
an allowed value of
E-- on the horizontal,
and an allowed value of
q, such that cosine qL
is the vertical value.
Everyone cool with that?
So, what val-- Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] p
degeneracy for values of q.
Like for a specific
q, we're going
to find a lot of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: For specific
values of q, why does it--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
horizontal line.
You'll have a lot of
intersections, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's, excellent.
OK.
So, good.
So, there are two ways
of answering that.
That's a very good question.
So, the question
is, look, this is
slightly funny state of affairs.
If we plot-- if we take a
horizontal line-- corresponding
to a particular value q, it
hits at various different values
of the energy.
Excellent observation.
So, let me make two
points about that.
The first point is that when we
defined q, how did we define q?
We said the translate be
L on phi Eq was equal to E
to the iqL phi eq.
But now, suppose we take q
to q plus 2pi upon L, OK?
OK, so if we take q
to q plus 2pi upon L,
we don't do anything
to the eigenvalue.
So, that's not enough
to specify which
function we're talking about.
Because we changed
the value of q,
and it doesn't change
the eigenvalue.
So, you can't just
focus on the eigenvalue.
There are two ways of
thinking about that.
One is, look, since q
and q plus 2 pi upon L
give you the same
eigenvalue of TL,
we should just think
of them as equivalent.
So, one, we should just--
look, any time you have q,
and you add plus 2pi upon L,
you just think of this as q.
It's not different.
There's just, you know,
q now is valued periodic.
If you shift q by 2 pi,
you're actually back
at the same point.
So, q is now a
periodic variable.
And but, that's not enough.
Different values of these
q correspond to different
values-- the same eigenvalue.
So, you're getting multiple
solutions as a consequence.
But there's another way
to think about this.
Which is just in
terms of this graph.
In terms of this graph,
if what we're specifying
is cosine of qL, but we're not
specifying the value for q,
yeah?
So, if we instead plotted
this as a function of q,
without assuming q is
equivalent to 2pi q plus 2pi
upon L-- which we can do,
we're perfectly entitled
to do that-- what do we get?
What do you think you get?
For the free particle,
we know exactly what
we get for the free particle.
The parabola.
And if you just take this,
and I'm going to give you guys
the Mathematica files
for all these things.
Yeah, if you just take
this, and open it up,
instead of plotting it
in terms of cosine of qL,
plot it in terms of q,
that's exactly where you get.
The satisfying thing.
And I'm going to come back
to that in just a minute,
but it was a really
good question
and we'll come back to it.
Other questions?
OK, now, let's ask what
happens as we turn on g0.
As we turn on g0, the
solutions to this equation
are going to be
different, because it's
going to be a
difference equation.
So, let's do it.
So, here it is.
We have g0, we can tune it.
And I'm going to
slowly turn on g0.
And watch what happens
to these curves.
So, now we see
that the right hand
side of the yellowish curve
is now exceeding 1 and minus 1
in various places, right?
And why is it doing that?
Let's get some
reasonable down here.
So, why is it doing that's?
It's doing that because this
can now be greater than 1.
Cosine is bounded between 1
and minus 1, but this is not.
And so, we overshoot
in some places.
And what does this tell us?
What does this
really telling us?
What its really telling
us is that-- there we
go-- how do we find
allowed values of E and q
such that we have a good
energy eigenfunction which
is simultaneously and
eigenfunction of E and of TL?
We need to find points where
a horizontal line between 1
and minus 1 intersects
the right hand side curve.
But for the energies
between here--
this value of the energy, and
this value of the energy---
there is no such point.
The energies in
here-- any energy
in here-- in order for those
lines to intersect, line
must be greater than 1, or
less than minus 1 down here,
or here.
So, there's no
allowed value of q,
such that there's a solution
with energy between these two
points.
Everyone cool with that?
So, that's telling us that
there are values of energy where
there are no energy eigenvalues
with that corresponding energy.
Because there simply
aren't solutions
of this equation for any
value of q with that energy.
On the other hand, when
the right hand side
is between 1 and minus 1, we
have allowed values of energy.
We have a value of
q, and a value of E
that correspond to each
other, and they correspond
to a solution of the energy
eigenvalue equation and the TL
eigenvalue equation.
So, let's see what that looks
like in this presentation.
Oh, before I do, I want to say
one other thing about this.
Let's take this plot, and
let's use this periodicity.
So, this periodicity is going
to say that-- So, here's
pi upon L, here's minus pi
upon L-- let's see, yeah,
good-- there's minus pi
upon L, there's 2pi upon L,
and 2pi upon L. If
these guys are periodic,
than I could've just said,
look, at this point--
this is pi upon L,
and minus pi upon L--
I could've said this point
is the same as this point.
So, I could've taken this
whole bit of the curve,
and I could've
moved it over here.
Everyone cool with that?
Because this value of q, is
the same as this value, q.
This value of q, is the same
as this value of q, right?
So, I could have written this,
and if we just take this over,
you can see it's,
you know, symmetric.
As a consequence,
we get-- And so, we
can write-- we can draw--
this entire parabola folded up
into one region, using the
periodicity with q as 2pi
upon L. And when you fold
it up into one region,
just using q as periodic
with period 2pi over L,
and now noting that there
are several solutions
for every value q--
corresponding to how far out
on the parabola
you went-- now we
have a much simpler way of
presenting this, where we don't
need to see the whole parabola.
This is a real advantage.
When we plot things in
this way, the structure
of the energy bands
and energy gaps
becomes considerably
more simple.
So, let me do that.
First let me set the g to 0.
OK, so, here is
our free particle.
And let's look at that plot.
So, here's the plot that
I was just describing.
What you see here,
is the parabola.
And I've use a
periodicity to box it up
into one fundamental period
between pi and minus pi
upon L, OK?
And so, the blue
line corresponds
to the energy as
a function of q--
the allowed energy
as a function of q--
and what the green
background represents
is I'm going to put the
horizontal section in green
anytime there's an
allowed energy with that.
So, energy, here,
is vertical, and q
is on the horizontal, going
between minus pi over L and pi
over L. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I might be
getting this just out,
but is there a reason that as
the energy increases the bands
get broader and broader?
Is that just an
artifact of the math,
or is there a good
physical reason for that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there're both.
So, one way to think about it,
so just purely mathematically,
this is saying that cosine
of qL is cosine of root EL.
So, as we make the energy
larger, and larger,
some small variation
in q is going
to correspond to a
quadratic variation in E.
And that's what's
making it stretched out.
If we plotted this as a
function of kL, instead of E,
then it would have looked
much more constant period, OK?
So, that's the
mathematical answer.
The physical answer is this,
if we have some potential,
if I put you in a finite
well-- So, there you are.
You're in a finite well.
And you look at the ceiling,
you're like, damn it!
And so, that's
frustrating, right?
And it's deeply frustrating
if it's a deep well,
but if it's a shallow well,
it's not all that big a deal,
you climb out.
Being in a deep potential--
being at low energy,
compared to the
potential-- means
that you're tightly
bound, right?
Takes a huge amount
of energy to get out.
And as a consequence, what
you saw in your problem
set is that the
bands are quite thin.
But as you get closer,
and closer to the top,
or as you go to higher energy,
the thickness of that band
grows as a measure of
the fact that you're
less tightly constrained
by the potential.
OK?
Good.
So, that's the
physical intuition.
Did that make sense?
Good.
OK, so, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
g0 different from 0,
do you ever get to the point
where the solution is always
inside the [INAUDIBLE].
So, like the bumps [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ah!
Good.
Let's look.
So, let's answer
that by looking.
So, the question is, basically,
look, as you crank up g0,
do you ever lose
the bands entirely,
or do the bands just disappear?
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: As you get
to higher energies.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, as you
go to higher energies.
Good.
So, we can answer that.
Let me do that in two ways.
So, the first thing
I want to do is
I want to ask the first
of that question, which
is what happens as we
turn on the potential?
Here we have the free particle,
let's turn on the potential.
We know what
happens down here, I
want to ask what happens to the
picture of the allowed values
of q and the allowed
value-- sorry,
the allowed values of energy--
and their corresponding values
of q.
So, here, it's easy.
This particular point
on the blue line
corresponds to a value of
the energy, and a value of q.
What happens to
those allowed pairs
as we increase the potential?
And as we increase
the potential,
you can see on the left
that the right hand
side is exceeding 1 and minus 1.
And correspondingly,
on the right,
here the red dot is what was
the free particle-- parabola--
and the blue line is
the actual solutions.
What you find is when you
turn on the potential,
the actual solution moves
away from the free particle
line in a very particular way.
In particular, for this value
of energy-- around 100--
there are absolutely no
allowed energy eigenstates.
There are no solutions.
And so as correspondingly,
that area is not shaded green.
There are only solutions
where you have this blue line.
Everyone see that?
So, we get these gaps.
And we get bands of
continuously allowed energies.
And then gaps between
those allowed bands.
And I'm going to post this-- the
guy-- to play with on Stellar.
So, now, let's go up to
very, very large values
of the interaction.
OK, and let's see
what happens when
you go to large of interaction.
Well, one thing that happens
it that Mathematica sort of
panics down here, so it
lost an entire band, which
shouldn't happen.
Let's try this, there we go.
That's better There's
a wonderful book
on spectral methods in
solving differential equations
by a guy named Boyd.
And he's pithy, if
somewhat degenerate,
and he says at one point,
the definition of an idiot
is-- or he says,
idiot definition,
someone who doesn't reproduce
their numerics twice
with different parameter values.
And so, we could have just lost
this band and written a paper,
oh, band's disappear!
This is great!
Never believe Mathematica
until you've checked it.
So, anyway, here you see a band,
and another band, and another.
But what's happened is the
bands become very thin.
But that makes sense from
the earlier intuition.
We're making the
potential much stronger.
We're more tightly binding
particles into wells.
And as a consequence, the bands
are very tightly restricted.
And that fits very
much with what
we saw on your phet simulations.
OK, but-- hold on for
one sec-- coming back
to the question over
here-- yours-- coming back
to that question, if you look at
higher and higher energy, what
you're going to find is that
the bands get wider and wider,
and the gaps get
thinner and thinner,
as you go to high-- well,
it's a little more complicated
than that, it depends on
exactly what you're doing,
but-- the bands get
wider, the gaps get wider,
but both of them don't get
wider at the same rate.
So, this is actually
something you'll
look at on your problem set.
But the important
thing you will find
is that the bands
never disappear.
Like a band in 1D doesn't just
close and disappear altogether,
and the bands don't overlap.
And here's an easy
way to understand
why the bands don't overlap.
Let's look at what
these states are.
So in particular, I want
to look at the states
at the bottom of each
loud energy band.
So, let's go back down
to small value of g0.
So, we have these
big thick bands
with a weak little potential.
We have big, thick
bands, little, tiny gaps,
and I want to look at the
states at the bottom of the gap.
Let's make it maybe
a little bit bigger.
So, we'll look at the states
at the bottom of the gap.
And there's an optional
problem in your problem set
that works through
the mechanics of this.
But I want to look
through it in some detail.
So, what we're plotting
here-- Did that work?
Crap.
Unfortunately,
this is-- OK, good.
So, here what we have
is the ground state
of the lowest band
at zero interaction.
So, here, is g0.
And it's 0.001,
it's basically 0.
As I turn on the delta
function potentials,
what's going to happen to the
lowest energy state, which
is just the constant,
has momentum 0.
What's going to
happen to this guy?
Well, we saw from this guy,
that the lowest energy state
got a little bit of a gap there.
There is no state
at 0 energy anymore.
There's now a state only at
slightly positive energy.
A wave from what would have been
the zero energy, zero momentum
state.
Everyone see that?
There's this little gap
between 0, and the bottom.
And if we make the
interaction bigger,
we'll see that a
little more obviously.
Here's the red is
the zero energy,
and it goes up to finite energy.
But has that lowest state
developed any nodes?
Does the lowest state in
a 1D potential have nodes?
No, right?
There's nodes here.
0 nodes, then one, then two.
And do they ever switch orders?
Does it ever go zero, two, one?
No.
There's the node theory.
So, what happens to
these wave functions
is all the wave
functions continuously
change as we turn
on the potential,
but they don't switch order.
Their ordering is completely
fixed by the number of nodes.
So, let's watch what happens
to the actual wave functions.
So, here's that
lowest state, and I'm
going to turn on the potential.
What's going to happen?
Well, we're going to see the
effect of the delta function.
And there, you see the effect of
the delta function turning on.
And as we crank
up the potential,
you see that the wave
function generates
a kink where there
is a delta function.
And that state has zero nodes.
That's the ground state.
Everyone cool with that?
OK.
Similarly, let's go to 0.
Whoops.
Oh, shoot.
Don't give me
infinite expressions.
You're not allowed
to divide by 0.
Oh, shoot!
OK, here's the second
excited state, this guy.
And let's look at what happens
as we turn up the potential
now.
Exactly the same thing.
We see a little kink.
We don't get new nodes.
But what we do get are
kinks at the potential.
This is for the special case of
the delta function potential,
but it's illustrative
of everything else.
So, going back to the
bands, what's going on here
is that these states
are getting compressed--
they're getting
pushed up together--
but they're not getting
swapped in their order.
OK?
And this was in the service
of a question that was asked.
What was the last question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, I
don't remember exactly
which questions I was
answering, I'm sorry, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I think it was
if you lose the bands.
PROFESSOR: Ah, yeah.
If you lose the bands.
So, you know by the node theorem
that you never lose states.
States with three
nodes can't disappear.
That same with
three nodes always
has to be between
the state with two--
thank you-- between the
state with two nodes,
and the state with four nodes.
And they can't just disappear.
So, those gaps never disappear.
And they never overlap,
because they never
cross each other, again,
by the node theorem.
All you get is things
separating into bands
and squishing together,
or spreading back apart
and becoming the free particle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] strange
periodic potential and you'll
get the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Indeed.
Indeed.
So, that's exactly right.
So, the observation is, look,
this was for the delta function
potential, but we didn't have
to use delta function barriers.
We could have use
little square barriers,
I could have used little, you
know, goat-shaped barriers.
I could have used whatever.
And there's going
to be some answer.
And how's it going to change?
Well, the way it's going to
change is where the bands are,
how wide they are, and
how wide the gaps are.
But the rest of the story goes
over in exactly the same way.
The energy eigenfunctions
take the form E
to the iqx times the
periodic function.
Cool?
OK, and on your
problem set, where
you're gonna show-- one of
the things you're gonna show--
and I love this result,
because it encapsulates
so much physics,
you're going to show
that if you have a potential--
a single potential barrier--
and you know the
reflection amplitude,
and the transmission
amplitude-- or really, you just
need to know one-- if
you know the reflection
amplitude-- if it's
parity symmetric-- then
you can write down the
band structure entirely
in terms of-- you can
write down an equation
for the allowed energies
as a function of q--
entirely in terms
of the reflection
amplitude and the phase shift.
Which is an amazing fact.
So, you know about reflection
off of one barrier,
you make an infinite
lattice of those barriers,
and you deduce the structure
of the allowed energy bands
and gaps, which is cool.
So, the scattering information--
as I kept promising--
contains a huge amount of
the physics of your system.
So, we saw that it
contains bound energies,
but it also contains
these band gaps.
OK, questions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] If we
make the g0 go to infinity,
would that approach
a single [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
Excellent.
So, the question was, what
happens as g0 goes to infinity,
is it like getting single wells?
So, let's look at that.
It's a very good observation.
So, here's a band
between-- I really
should put a line
here-- but between here,
and here, we have this band.
And that corresponds to
between here, and here.
As we make g0 stronger, the
derivation from simple cosine
gets larger and larger.
The amplitude gets
larger and larger,
and those bands get steeper,
and steeper, and steeper.
And the allowed energy bands
get thinner, and thinner,
and thinner.
And, in fact, they get
so thin, that Mathematica
loses track of some of them,
which is the annoyance.
So, here we have
very, very thin bands.
What happens is we take
g0 very, very large.
So, let's make it 400.
And, you can see, Mathematica
doesn't like that.
It's totally lost the band.
So, let's try something
a little less extreme.
Oh, no, still too
big for Mathematica.
Eight, you can do
it, little buddy.
Ah, there we go!
We can keep tack of one.
So, what's happening
is these bands
are getting extremely thin.
And what's happening,
you're erecting
infinitely high barriers between
each period in the lattice.
And if you have
infinitely high barriers,
what are the
allowed eigenvalues?
It's the same as the energy
eigenvalues of the infinite
well, because it has to be 0 at
those infinite barriers, right?
So, all of those states-- all
of the states in the band--
become degenerate, and have
the same energy, the energy
of the periodic well,
or of the infinite well.
Very good question.
OK.
So, let's let Mathematica
relax a little bit again.
Well done.
OK.
And so, I want to
quickly ask why do we
have bands in the first place?
Why do we have gaps?
So, what's going on?
Why do we have gaps
in the first place?
AUDIENCE: Because our
math told us we had to?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
This is an excellent answer.
Not the one I was looking for.
The answer is a good answer
because we did the calculation
and that's what the
calculation tells us.
And that is a completely valid
answer for a theorist, right?
At this stage of writing
down what your theory is
and making a prediction.
But before you can write that
paper, publish it, and say,
aha!
I've discovered bands!
You must have an explanation
to the following question, why?
How do you know your
calculation was correct,
before you've done
the experiment?
So, one answer is, of course,
you do the experiment,
and it fits like a champ.
But that's not a very
illuminating experiment
as you know you're going to find
departures from your theory,
you want to improve
the situation.
You want some intuition
about why this works.
And you actually all know
the physics behind this.
And we did it on the
first problem set.
Remember the experiment that
we studied on a problem set,
the Davis and Germer Experiment,
where you send plane waves
onto a crystal, and due
to interference effects,
the transmission amplitude
changes-- the transition
probability changes-- as
a function of the angle.
And the reason it changes as a
function of the angle was you
had a crystal plane, right?
So, atom, atom, atom, atom,
atom, atom, atom, atom,
and a plane wave sent
in could scatter off
of any of these
scatterers, right?
Or it could transmit and
scatter off a further one down.
And if you look
at the scattering
off different scatterers, if the
effect of those scatterings--
so one down, and then one
much deeper down-- if those
interfere destructively,
then that's
going to suppress
the reflection.
And if they interfere
constructively,
it's gonna enhance
the reflection.
So, usually we think about that
Davis and Germer Experiment,
we think about it as a function
of the angle of incidence,
either straight at, or
as a function of angle.
And we ask, how does
the transmission
depend on those angles?
But there's another
way to phrase
that question, you can
ask, look, on average,
how deep does that wave go?
Does the wave propagate
through the crystal?
Or if it doesn't propagate
through the crystal,
it's gonna exponentially
decay with some wavelength,
with some decay-length.
And what you find is that
whether the wave propagates in,
or whether it decays
exponentially,
depends on the energy
and the lattice
spacing of that crystal.
And this is exactly
the same thing,
only we have a crystal
in both directions.
We don't have empty air and
we're sending in a plane wave.
Now we have a plane wave,
can it propagate through?
Well, for some energies,
it'll propagate
with continuous energy, or
it'll propagate continuously.
And for some energies, it
will damp out exponentially.
But if it damps
out exponentially,
and it damps out exponentially
in the other direction too,
then you don't get
any solution at all.
It just completely dies.
So, what's really
going on here is
the fact that all of these
scatterers in this lattice
are scattering centers.
And if you send a little wave
packet in-- which you should
think of as a superposition
of energy eigenstates--
if you send a wave
packet in, the probably
to get-- the
probability amplitude
to get from here to here--
is the probability amplitude
to go from here to here,
plus to scatter through--
to transmit through and reflect
back-- plus to transmit,
transmit, reflect, reflect--
or sorry, transmit, transmit,
reflect, transmit-- plus all
the other crazy things you
could do.
And you have to sum up
over all those terms.
You have to sum the
effect of how do you
get from here to here?
Every possible way
to get from here
to there, a la the
two slit experiment.
Sum of over all
possible paths where
you bounce around scattering
off each of these scattering
centers.
And that's why the
band structure's
encoded in the
reflection amplitudes
from an individual
scattering center.
Because now, it's just a
common [INAUDIBLE] problems
of how many different paths,
and summing up the phase
that you get.
OK?
So, it's just about coherent
and incoherent scattering.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] crystal
and I have an electron.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If I sent the electron
through the crystal in just
the right way, with
just the right energy,
won't it just go through in
some states, without seeing it?
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
Excellent.
So, the question is under
what conditions can you
send an electron and
it'll just cruise right on
through the potential?
So, let's answer that question.
That's exactly the
right question.
So, let's pick up from here.
And I want to ask,
what have we learned?
So, what are the lessons
for g0 equal to 0?
So, the first lesson is
that the energy eigenvalues,
E eigenvalues, are
restricted to lie
within a band-- this
bands-- and the bands
are separated by gaps.
Two, the energy
eigenstates-- so this
was eigenvalues-- the energy
eigenstates are all extended.
And we didn't even need
to find the full solution
of this equation to know that.
All we needed to know is
that it was a solution.
That the energy eigenfunction
are eigenfunctions
of the translation
operator as well.
And that tells us the
probability of that form.
And that tells us what the
probability distribution is,
which is the norm squared
of that guy, is independent,
it's periodic.
And if it's periodic,
it can't fall off
exponentially one
direction or the other.
So, we've seen that the
eigenfunctions are all
extended, and so
as a consequence,
we have to build wave packets.
So, therefore, we must
build wave packets.
And, again, the form of
the wave packets, psi
is equal to the integral
dq f of q-- sorry,
I'll say fq0-- sharply peaked
around the point q0 of q.
And then the wave
function's E to the iqz
minus omega t times
ru of x sub q.
OK.
So, we have to
build wave packets.
So, three, this tells us
that those wave packets
move with group velocity,
by the same logic
as for the free
particle, V group is
equal to d omega dk--
or dq-- evaluated at q0.
OK, where q0 is where our
wave packet is sharply peaked.
So, that's already telling
you something really cool.
Look at this lowest band.
Let's make this a
little more reasonable.
So, let's look at
this lowest band.
And in particular, I'm
going to make this big.
So, focus in on the
lowest energy band, here.
So, there's the
lowest energy band.
It goes from the top of the
band to the bottom of the band.
It's just a little bit away
from the free particle,
because we're looking
at a relatively
weakly, perturbed system.
I chose a small value of q0.
Actually, let's make it a
little more exaggerated.
OK, so there's the free
particle curve, the red one,
and the blue one
is our actual band.
So, that's the energy
as a function of q.
And let's make it even bigger.
This one goes to 11.
Let's see.
OK.
And so what you can see is
the following, it looks,
again, it's looks sort of
like a parabola at the bottom.
And at the top, it curves
over, and, actually,
goes to zero derivative.
And it has to, because
it's got to be periodic.
Because q is periodic with
period 2pi over L. So,
what does that tell
you about the velocity?
Well, let's look
at the velocity.
V group velocity, of wave
packet with-- whoops,
say, here's 0-- as a function
of q between minus 2pi over L,
and 2pi over L.
What is the group velocity?
And here's what I mean.
What I mean is let's
build a wave packet which
has a reasonably
well-localized momentum,
say, at this value of q.
So, I built a little wave
packet it has a peak here,
and what does that
wave function do?
Well, it has a group velocity.
And the group velocity
is given by d omega dq.
And now, we can't solve
that equation analytically,
because it's [INAUDIBLE].
But we can see, just by
eyeball, what this does.
When q is equal to 0,
what's the group velocity?
Yeah.
It's the slope, right?
D omega dq.
So, what's d omega
dq at the origin?
0, right? 'Cause
it's just horizontal.
So, it's 0.
Good.
What about a little
bit to the right of 0?
What about if I give it
a small positive q-- wave
packet localized with
a small positive q?
It's got a little bit
of a slope now, right?
Little bit of a positive slope.
So, it increases.
But then, it reaches a
maximum slope, halfway
through the domain.
So, here, it hits
a maximum value,
and then the slope
comes back down.
And if we'd went the
other way, if we'd
made q a little bit negative,
the slope becomes negative.
And that's the velocity.
So, that's a slightly
strange thing.
As we increase q, it
increases the velocity.
Increasing q increases
the velocity for a while.
That's just like k and momentum.
Momentum is h bar k.
So, that would be
increasing the group
velocity for a free particle.
But now, as we increase the q
to a reasonably large value,
to 2pi upon L-- oh, sorry, this
is pi upon L, and pi upon L--
so, if we do this to pi upon
2L, or roughly, to the middle,
we get to a maximum value.
And if we increase q
further, what happens?
The velocity goes down, right?
If we increase q further,
the velocity goes.
This is strange.
For a free particle, if
you had momentum h bar k,
and you increased k, what
happens to the expectation-?
What happens to
the group velocity?
If you increase
the momentum, what
happens to the group
velocity for a free particle?
AUDIENCE: [MURMURS]
PROFESSOR: It's gonna
increase, right?
But not for a particle in
the periodic potential.
The wave packet, as you
increase the crystal momentum,
q, past this maximum, as you
you actually decrease
the velocity.
And, in fact, if you
keep increasing q,
eventually the
velocity goes to 0.
And you increase
q a little more,
and it actually goes negative.
So, this is a funny
thing, it's not
behaving like normally you'd
think of as a momentum.
And, indeed, is there momentum
conservation in this system?
No.
We have a periodic potential.
There are forces at work.
Is momentum conserved?
No.
This is not a system that
conserves a momentum.
Momentum can be exchanged
between the particle
and the potential.
Q is a good quantity.
It's the eigenfunction of
TL, and that does commute
with the energy operator.
So, it's a perfectly
reasonable quantity.
But the momentum itself,
p, is not conserved.
So, this crystal
momentum, q, is not
the momentum, for
all these reasons.
But it plays a lot
of the same role,
especially near the
bottom of the band.
Near the top of the band,
it's a little bit funnier,
because if you increase q,
you get a negative velocity.
If you decrease q, you
get a positive velocity.
It's exactly the opposite of
what you'd normally expect.
But let's hold on to that
thought for a second.
So, there's another sense in
which the crystal momentum
is like a momentum.
And you're gonna show
this on your problem set.
But it's very important in
giving you some understanding--
some intuition-- about what
the crystal momentum is.
On your problem set,
you'll show the following.
Suppose I induce
a constant force.
For example, imagine
this particle
in my periodic
potential had a charge,
and I turn on a constant,
uniform electric field.
Then that particle experiences
a constant, uniform driving
force, which I can write as a
linearly increasing potential,
right?
So, what you showed
on the problem
set is that the force--
the expectation value
of the force-- is equal to--
for a wave packet-- sharply
localized around some
value, q0, the force,
it gives the time
rate of change, d dt,
of the expectation value of q.
So, if you turn on a
force, what happens
is q increases linearly.
Thank you.
It's so hard.
It's just so obviously 1.
So, if the force
is constant, then
h bar q increases constantly.
So, q just increases
linearly in time, yeah?
But that's funny.
Well, we'll come back
to that, just how
funny that is in just a-- yeah?
Question?
No, OK.
Well, let's think about
how funny that it.
Let's tackle this, right now.
So, imagine we start
with a wave packet, which
is well localized around
zero crystal momentum,
around q equals 0.
Then what is that wave
function doing in time?
How does that wave packet move?
What's its group velocity?
0.
So, it's just sitting there.
It's just little wave
packets slowly dispersing,
quantum mechanically, yeah?
But if we don't make it too
tightly constrained, and p
and 2 too tightly constrained.
And the dispersion could
be made quite slow.
So, it's just a
little wave packet,
localized around a
particular position.
And localized around
zero momentum,
and it's just sitting there.
Cool?
Now, let's apply a force.
What happens?
As we apply a force, a constant,
force with a positive sign.
Q is gonna increase.
So, the central value--
I should say, yeah-- so,
the central value
of our wave packet
is gonna go from 0 to
something slightly positive.
Because q is increasing.
What that means is
that the velocity is
increasing at first.
So, the velocity
is gonna increase,
and in equal units
of time it's gonna
march linearly along this way.
So, the particle is going
faster, and faster, and faster,
and faster.
And that makes sense.
You're driving the system by
putting on a constant force.
Of course it accelerates.
The velocity
accelerates linearly,
so the position
accelerates quadratically.
So, let's plot the
position-- expectation
value of the position--
as a function of time.
At zero time-- it's
at the origin--
it's at some trivial
position, x0.
As we increase time, velocity's
increasing linearly for awhile,
and the position is gonna
increase quadratically.
Everyone cool with that?
But eventually, at some point in
time, the velocity-- or the q--
is gonna get to the
point where we're
at the maximum allowed velocity.
And at that point, what is the
curve for x gonna look like?
It's gonna have an
inflection point.
And as we increase--
as we wait longer-- q
is gonna continue
linearly increasing, which
means the velocity is
going to slow down.
So, the thing slows down,
so its slope decreases,
until finally it's got
zero velocity again.
There we go-- zero
velocity-- dx dt.
And then what happens?
We keep forcing it.
It's a constant driving force.
But this is this,
by periodicity of q,
and the thing is, we increase
q further linearly in time.
As we increased q further,
the velocity becomes negative.
So, instead of continuing
to accelerate--
instead of continuing to move--
in a positive x direction,
it starts going backwards!
That's weird.
You're putting a force
in this direction,
and it's accelerating
in that direction.
That's a strange effect.
And as we continue,
eventually we
get to maximum
negative velocity.
Again, an inflection point.
And, at which
point, the velocity
starts getting less, and less
negative, or closer, and closer
to 0.
And we return.
And so, in some
period, capital T,
which is determined by how big
this constant driving force is,
the particle returns to
its original position.
Everyone see that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it
starting at q equals 0?
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
At q0 equals 0.
Exactly.
So, at first point, so this is
q equals 0, this is-- sorry,
q equals 0-- is
the initial point.
And x is equal to x0.
So, under this
process, the particle
goes through an oscillation,
called a Bloch Oscillation.
It's named after the guy
who invented the wave
functions, the Bloch
Wave Functions.
And this is a
deeply weird thing.
Normally, you think, well, look,
if I take a charged particle,
and I just put it in an
empty space, or in a box,
or whatever, and I turn
on an electric field,
what happens to it?
It accelerates.
But if you put that charged
particle in a periodic lattice,
like copper-- idealized copper,
here, perfect uniform lattice--
and you turn on an
electric field--
or you put a capacitor
plate across the thing--
that electron, at
first, wants to behave
like an electron in free space.
It wants to accelerate.
But then it finds out
it's in a lattice.
And it goes backwards.
And it just oscillates back
and forth, [INAUDIBLE]-like,
you know?
I really want to
get there, oh crap.
I really want to get there.
Oh no, I'm in a
periodic potential.
And it just oscillates
back and forth.
Is there any conductions
in this system
due to the electromagnetic
field that we've induced?
None.
That is a strange little beasty.
That is a strange,
strange property.
And yet, copper conducts.
Copper, which is
a uniform lattice
of ions-- of
potentials-- to which
electrons are stuck in bands.
Copper conducts!
The electrons don't do
this Bloch Oscillation.
How come?
Yeah.
It's not perfect.
And it's not perfect for
a whole bunch of reasons.
So, one reason it's not
perfect is that, so, first off,
in a lattice of, say,
copper, or whatever,
the ions have a finite mass.
So, what that means is
they're not stuck in place,
they also wiggle.
When the electron moves,
one of the ions move.
So, the whole thing
you should think
of as a little wiggling
piece of jello.
And as a consequence, they're
not perfectly periodic.
This does a bunch of things.
One is these are no longer the
exact energy eigenfunctions.
You now have to deal
with the oscillations
and wiggling of the lattice.
But more importantly,
here's something
that can happen-- and
electron can move along,
and it can kick one of these
ions-- it can bounce off
one of the ions-- and
scatter some of its momentum
into the ion.
Not into the rigid
lattice, but it
could just make one
of those ions wiggle.
So, it's changed the
structure of the lattice.
OK?
And what you can do then, is
you can have an electron that
is accelerating, and it hits
something, and it stops.
And it accelerates.
And it stops.
Accelerates, and it hits
something, then it stops.
OK?
So, when you have lots of
disorder in your system--
or when you allow the
electron to bounce off
things in the lattice-- you get
this effective conductivity.
Things start their
Bloch Oscillation,
then they collide, and
scatter off their momentum,
and go back to zero
momentum, but they've
moved over a little bit in
their oscillation already.
They move up, and they move.
So, what that picture looks
like is, you accelerate,
and then, boom, you scatter,
and you fall back down
to zero momentum
by scattering off
your momentum into
something else.
Same thing, you move
up, and then, now, you
have zero momentum again.
You move up, you have
zero momentum again.
You move up, you
have zero momentum.
You move up, you have
zero momentum, again.
And so, you get this
effective drifting
of the electrons, pointed
out by a guy named Drude.
That gives you, effectively,
a conductivity and a solid.
Now, there are a
bunch of other effects
that are important
for conductivity.
Normally, we think of disorder
as something that, you know,
if you make things
messy, they're
probably gonna transmit
less well, right?
But disorder is absolutely
essential for conductivity
in real solids.
Both for this reason,
because you scatter off
of fluctuations, but also, when
you have a chunk of copper,
it's not a chunk of copper.
It's a chunk of
copper, but it's got,
you know, here and there,
there's a little carbon
atom that got stuck, and
maybe there's a bit of nickel,
and, you know,
palladium, or, you know,
Berkelium-- pretty unlikely,
but could be there-- so,
you have all sorts of schmutz
sort of distributed around.
And, again, those
are things that
make the potential not periodic.
And, so, will change the
conservation of this q.
OK?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but if you actually
managed to put a
alternating current--
or an alternating voltage--
at the right frequency,
you could actually drive
the electrons from one side
to the other in this fashion?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so, I--
AUDIENCE: --even though
the conventional way
of thinking about
alternating currents
is that the electrons
really don't move at all.
PROFESSOR: That's a
very good observation.
It's a little subtle, so
come to my office hours
and ask me about that.
But there's an interesting--
For a very specific reason,
because it's easy
and unambiguous,
I chose look the DC.
But you're right,
looking at the AC,
is really a very
entertaining example.
So, yeah, I'm not
gonna get into it.
There's a cool story with
parametric resonance.
And yeah, there's a
very nice story there.
Come to my office
hours, because that
is a particularly fun story.
OK, but I want to do
one last thing on this
before we move on.
So, in this process, something
very strange happened.
When we got to the top of
the potential, what we found
was as we increase--
as we continue
constant, positive force--
the velocity decreased.
Yeah?
That is weird.
Normally, when I take
a force, and I take
some object with some
mass, and I take a force
and I apply it to the mass,
and then the acceleration
is the force
divided by the mass.
In particular, mass is
always a positive thing,
so if I take my force, and I
divide it by the positive mass,
I get an acceleration in the
same direction as the force.
But here, we have
an applied force,
and we get an acceleration
in the opposite direction.
I thought our particle
had a positive mass.
Didn't it have a positive mass?
We started off with
a positive mass.
We should still have
So, what's going on here?
Well, we have a rule for
calculating what the mass is.
We take the expectation
value of the momentum
and divide by the
group velocity.
So, let's find out what
the mass is for this guy.
And I'll do that here.
So, this is a slightly
surreal moment
with a nice little codon.
So, I'm going to write that
expression for the mass
slightly differently.
And you're gonna show in
your problem set-- PSet--
you're gonna show that that
definition of the mass-- M star
is p upon the group
velocity-- leads
to the following expression, you
can write that as-- you can use
that to derive-- that the mass
can be written as 1 upon h bar
squared d squared E dq squared.
So, the group velocity
is the first derivative
of the energy with respect to q.
The mass-- or really
q over the mass--
is proportional to the second
derivative, the curvature.
Everyone see that?
So, this should not be
an obvious equation,
unless you're breathtakingly
good at calculus in your head.
It's just chain
rule, but it does
take a little bit
of careful thinking,
because it's a
physical argument,
it's not a rigorous
mathematical argument.
You're gonna do it
on your problem set.
So, let's take this
expression and let's see
what the effective mass is.
What is the mass
of our particle?
Now, here, when I see what
is the mass of our particle?
I mean a very precise thing.
What is the mass of
the object moving
in this periodic potential?
That's what I mean.
What is the mass of this thing?
And we have a definition for it.
Here it is.
And let's plot this 1 over mass.
So, let's plot this 1 over mass.
Oh, that's not the
way I wanna draw it.
Yeah.
Yeah, OK, good.
So, here-- oh, shoot--
so, let's do it this way.
So, I want to plot 1 over
mass, in the vertical,
as a function of q.
And here is q is equal
to 0, and here is 1
upon mass is equal to 0.
So, at the bottom of the
band-- and this is pi upon L,
and minus pi upon L. At the
bottom of at the band, at q
equals 0, what is the mass?
Well, here's the velocity,
and there's the band.
So, what's the mass at
the bottom of the band?
Tell me properties about it.
Is it 0?
Yeah.
There's still some curvature.
It's approximated by
some parabola, right?
It's even.
And, in fact, you can take that
equation and derive properties
about it.
But it's some curvy thing.
You can see that.
It's more obvious if we look
at a higher energy band.
So, here's the minimum.
Here's what it would
have been if we
didn't have a potential, right?
But here's the minimum, and it's
nice and curvy, and at the top,
again, it's nice and curvy.
But it's got a second derivative
there, that's non-zero.
Everyone agree with that?
Now, here's the thing I want to
ask, is that second derivative
the same as it would have been
if we had g arbitrarily small?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Not so much.
No, if g was much lower,
the second derivative
would be a bit different.
OK.
So, in particular, this
is some funny value.
And I'm just gonna
give it a name.
It's gonna have some value at 0.
And, in particular,
it is positive.
Everyone agree with that?
But there's a point here--
there's an inflection point--
where this thing has
zero second derivative.
And that inflection
point is the same point
where the velocity
becomes a maximum,
because the velocity's
a first derivative.
So, when the velocity's
at a maximum,
the second derivative has a 0.
It's the derivative of the
first velocity, zero slope.
And so, at that
inflection point,
the velocity is 0--
or sorry, the velocity
is a maximum-- and 1
upon the mass, goes to 0.
And then, if we increase
q further, what happens?
1 over m star goes negative.
And it reaches a minimum
at pi over L, come back,
and, again, repeats.
So, it's periodic.
I'm just artistically
challenged.
So, how can this possibly be?
Right?
So, first off, what
this is telling
us is that we have a
point where the mass is 0.
It's positive around the
origin, where things normally
behave intuitively.
It goes to 0-- 1
over the mass-- goes
to 0, which tells me
that the mass, m star,
is going to infinity.
1 over the mass going to 0?
Mass must be going to infinity.
What does that mean?
Well, what does it
mean for something
to be infinitely massive?
It mean f equals ma, if it's
infinitely massive-- then let's
write that as acceleration
is force over m star-- then
that tells you that
if you apply a force,
you get no acceleration.
But that's exactly what we saw.
We get to this point, we
keep applying our force,
and the velocity stays constant.
There's no acceleration.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in this equation,
that's an external force, right?
PROFESSOR: That's
an external force.
AUDIENCE: So, only--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yeah.
Purely external force.
I put a capacitor plate
across my piece of metal.
AUDIENCE: So, my
next question would
be is it all that insane then?
Because, like, you haven't
calculated the net force
on the object, so to speak,
and so there is the potential.
And so, yeah, the net
force is zero, sure,
you're applying force, but
it's not going anywhere.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's not
a complete answer to what's
going on here, but it's
a very good observation.
So, let me rephrase
that slightly.
So, look, I'm doing a
slightly strange thing.
I'm applying an external
force, and I'm not
treating it quantum
mechanically,
I'm treating this particle
quantum mechanically.
That's clearly stupid.
We should treat everything
quantum mechanically,
and derive the results
in that fashion.
It turns out, in this case,
that the negative effective mass
doesn't go away if we treat the
electromagnetic field quantum
mechanically.
So, you're absolutely
correct, but it's not
enough to sort of make us
comfortable with the result.
It doesn't change this result.
But you're absolutely correct
that that's an important thing
to do if we want to be honest.
But this is a perfectly good
approximation for our purposes.
So, the mass goes infinite,
and then it goes a negative!
1 over the mass goes negative,
so that's ridiculous,
but that's exactly
what we wanted.
The acceleration is the
force divided by the mass,
but we found that when we apply
a force in this direction,
we get an acceleration
in this direction.
That's a negative coefficient,
so, in particular, here's
what I want to think about.
I want to ask the following
question, this value
of the mass-- even
around the bottom,
this should already be
disturbing observation--
because this value
of the mass is not
the same as the mass of
our original particle.
And the way you can
see that is if you
go to various strong coupling,
then this band shrinks down.
It becomes very thin,
and the second derivative
becomes arbitrarily
small, which means
the mass becomes
arbitrarily large.
So, the mass is getting
larger and larger
as we crank up the potential--
the effective mass--
of whatever this thing
is that's moving.
But this is strange.
The thing that's
moving is our particle.
It has mass, m.
Everyone agree with that?
What is going on here?
And here, I want to
do an experiment.
And my experiment--
AUDIENCE: [MURMURING]
PROFESSOR: So, yeah, the
seamless pong ball company,
in recognition of my
contributions to physics
and $3, has given me a series
of ping pong balls, with which,
I'm going to do the
following experiment.
OK.
Here's the calculation
I want to do.
The lesson I want you
to take away from this,
is that you've got to
be very careful what
you mean by, "the
mass" of an object.
Take one of these
ping pong balls,
I'm not gonna do the
whole experiment for you,
but I'll tell you the set up.
Take a ping pong ball, and
the first thing I want to do
is, I want to measure it's mass.
Well, what do you mean
by measure its mass?
Well, I'm gonna take it, and
I'm gonna put it in a vacuum,
you know, we could take it
to France to were they do
the-- And take the
ping pong ball--
ANNOUNCEMENT: One,
two, three, four.
One, two, three, four.
One, two.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: We're just
gonna turn that down.
OK.
ANNOUNCEMENT: One,
two, three, four.
One, two, three, four.
PROFESSOR: Can we kill that?
OK, so.
So, we take our ping pong ball,
and we put some mass over here,
with a known mass, and
we put it on a scale,
and we wait until this
goes to the vertical,
and we declare the mass.
And what we find is that
the mass of our ping pong
ball-- this is, you know, not
the greatest ping pong balls--
but by legislation, this is
supposed to be about 2.7 grams,
or people get in fistfights.
So, the mass of
the ping pong ball
needs to be about 2.7 grams.
And, meanwhile, the
radius of this guy
is about 20 millimeters,
so 2 centimeters.
Yeah, that's about right.
And yeah.
So, this is supposed
to-- morally--
it's supposed to
be 2 centimeters.
And so, if you go through this
and you compute the density
from these guys-- so,
this gives you a volume--
and if you compute the density,
the density is about 12.4
by regulation.
Now, I've done this experiment,
and I've done this measurement.
And I must've used
very cheap balls,
because I got a very,
very low density.
I got-- oh sorry, this is
the wrong way to do it--
the density is equal to
1, in usual CGS units,
is 1 upon 12.4.
And I can write that as 1
upon 12.4 times the density
of water.
OK?
Now, when I did this
experiment, I got 1 over 20.
So, I was probably using
very cheap ping pong balls.
But if you look at the
regulations on Wikipedia,
this is what you're
supposed to get.
Let's assume these are perfect.
So, you do this.
There's the mass.
That is the mass.
That's what I mean by the mass.
You take a scale,
you weigh the thing!
Right?
Does anyone object to my
definition of the mass?
It's an observational,
empirical process
for determining the mass.
If I take my mass, OK?
And now I ask the following
question, if I take some water,
and I pull my ping pong ball,
and I put it under water,
and I put a spring
scale here, and they
measure the force
on this ping pong
ball, what will the force be?
Well, the force will
be-- and let's just call
this ten, because the
calculation's going
to be horrible otherwise-- well,
whatever, let's call it 12.
So, the force-- and
another way to write this
is that rho water is
equal to 12 rho ping pong
ball-- I did math there.
So, the force-- we know this
from Archimedes-- the force
is a combination of the
weight of the ping pong
ball down, so, it's going to be
the density times the volume.
So, the volume times rho ping
pong ball down, so, minus.
Plus the volume
times rho water up,
because that's the weight of
the water displaced, right?
So, your weight down, minus the
weight of the water displaced.
Everyone cool with that?
Archimedes.
It's pretty well
known at this point.
So, this is equal to
the volume times rho
water minus rho ping pong ball.
And I can write this
as the volume times
rho water is 12 rho
ping pong balls,
so that's 12 minus 1
rho ping pong ball.
That's 11 rho ping pong ball.
But this is equal to 11
times the weight of the ping
pong ball-- oh sorry-- 11 times
the mass of the ping pong ball.
The volume times the density.
So, mass ping pong ball.
Now, there's an important thing
that I forgot to add here,
what did I forget to add?
G. Right?
It's the force is
the mass times g.
OK, g, g, and g.
So, we get that the force is
equal to 11 m ping pong ball g.
Everyone agree with that?
I haven't done anything sneaky.
And so, as a consequence,
what this predicts
is that if I take the
force and I divide it
by the mass of the
ping pong ball,
I get 11 times the
acceleration of gravity.
And here's what that predicts,
that predicts that when I let
go of this thing,
what should happen?
It should accelerate
upward through the water
at 11 times the acceleration
of gravity, which
is roughly 10 meters
per second squared.
So, 110 meters per
second squared.
Does that sound right?
Just intuitively,
does that sound right?
If you pull something
like a ping pong
ball, or a beach ball
or something underwater,
what happens when
you let go of it?
Well, at this point,
I'm going to remind you
that physics is an
empirical science.
So, let's see if we can do this.
OK, now, what's
supposed to happen
is this thing is supposed to
shoot out at nine times-- or 11
times-- the
acceleration of gravity.
So, it just shoots through
this thing much faster
than equivalently.
So which one's
going to hit first?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Should it
come out, or should it
hit the ground first?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
the ping pong ball.
Great, that's helpful.
Uh-huh.
So, what's gonna happen first?
Is the ping pong ball
gonna hit the surface,
or is it gonna come
flying out of the water?
This is accelerating with
the acceleration of gravity.
And this it's accelerating up
with 11 times the acceleration
of gravity.
So, let's do the experiment.
And this is what
they pay me for.
Oh.
This would be much
more satisfying
if we had a nice long-- how do I
want to phrase this-- cylinder.
Oh, shoot!
Stop.
So, it's best done with
a nice, long cylinder,
but let's do this.
So, which one wins?
AUDIENCE: [MURMURS]
PROFESSOR: Gravity wins, right?
And why?
Intuitively, why does this work?
AUDIENCE: [MURMURING]
PROFESSOR: I am neglecting
the drag effect,
but I'm not really heating
up the water all that much.
I mean, it's not
like the dissipation
is all that significant.
The dissipation of the momentum,
which is drag-- the friction--
is not the most important
thing for our purposes here.
That water hasn't
heated up at all.
So, what's going on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so
here's the question.
Has a mass of the ping pong
ball, my empty little ping pong
ball changed?
So, something like
that has to be true.
But what's the right answer?
The right answer is this,
the thing that's moving,
is not the ping pong ball.
The ping pong ball is
interacting with the fluid.
And as a ping pong
ball accelerates,
it drags the fluid
along with it.
And as it goes
faster, and faster,
it drags more and more of
the fluid along with it.
And as it's dragging more
and more of that fluid,
the effective mass
of the entire object
that's moving-- which
is now the ping pong
ball, and all of its associated
water-- is increasing.
And now, if you take that force,
which was constant, and divide
by this growing
effective mass, you
find that the acceleration
rapidly falls off.
And you get a terminal velocity.
And you know this
works, because if you
blow a bubble under water,
it doesn't shoot upwards
with an infinite acceleration.
It goes glurg, glurg, glurg.
And this idea, this idea
of the effective mass
of a particle changing
with its state of motion,
is an idea called
renormalization.
And it plays an essential role,
not just in particle physics,
but in all of modern
condensed matter physics.
And we'll pick up at
this point next time.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]